damn thank you why don't you watch where
you're going here let me help you with
that ma'am
seriously McCrystal gun was sweetie you
got my message about Dubai yeah I'm glad
you're alright Adam then I'm just
standing for your bathroom that's
something I was expecting and that's for
sure
any idea who hit us well I'm sure your
task force will come up with something
and that it won't be with the juggernaut
collective digs ever
and I though don't you think Interpol
sending your team that dragged him to
Dubai her first place Miller said they
were scrambling last-minute Intel we
were the only strike team available yeah
that's a lie
better get moving
the collective has been keeping tabs on
all task force divisions ever since we
slipped into one of them he's got a team
in oh man a hell of a lot faster you
guys so why send us I know
the task force is in Illuminati front we
all suspect doesn't make huge segmented
into an ambush was they wanted our club
to see something yeah officially
I'll go and see breath disappearing
see preface if a period I expect make a
senior prom I dream of it Alex
this is how we shine
where it's gotten even worse here in the
past few days everyone looking over
their shoulder terrified like us are
going to attack but maybe somebody
probably will treat people like animals
long enough they'll start acting like
animals just say that like there's
nothing we could do to stop it already
try two years ago didn't work out so
well so what are you saying we should
just give up that hatred and Prejudice
take over now with that I'm saying I can
only go after enemies I see Alex the men
who caused all this true power brokers
they're the ones I need to stop I
thought you were there
I do you meet the juggernaut girl trying
to stop doesn't mean turning a blind eye
to help me find them
you hate the city come on you're right
about divine about the Illuminati
meeting your team as witnesses and we
need to find out why
give you the order to manage melody they
probably came from someone higher up the
chain doesn't mean he's not in on it now
ever heard of the NSM your subnet sure
you have 29 directors use it to plan ops
and communicate privately in cyberspace
what's this whispered chip custom-made
wiretap device genius design it to fit
inside the innocence motherboard the
elusive Janus the leader of the
hacktivists I ever gonna meet this guy
someday maybe right now you need to
concentrate on Miller and find a way to
access her grandson's
Alex okay yeah let's get out of here
dear that
oh it's said hey you sound like [ __ ] how
you feeling little sore but Vera are you
okay
uh yeah yeah I'm okay I've been through
worse
Jesus how [ __ ] up is that to think huh
listen Alex my systems are acting up a
little so I've got to get checked out if
you want to meet her what no no no I'm
fine man you just take care of you this
girl's built tough give me a call when
you useful again okay talk to you soon
open blinds good morning Adam you have
one new message
from David Seraph play it Adam it's
David I know it's been a while but after
what happened in Prague yesterday look
son whatever reasons you had for not
getting in touch his last two years
life's too short I'm leaving for London
soon but give me a call you saved his
VidCon number yes Adam just activate
your TV system
Miller its Jensen it's good to finally
hear from you agent you doing okay sorry
about the downtime I'll get to the
office as soon as I can but my dogs took
a hit during the attack I need to get
them looked at of course there's a lot
of work ahead of us Jensen I'll see you
when you get in dr. Carla I need to pay
you a visit
Jensen now is actually a really good
time for me like right now something
wrong there are some guys in my bookshop
pissed off the valley gangster looking
guys so unless you want bloodshed the
day after a terror attack the front door
is the most peaceful option oh yeah
Figg you'll arity array you have heard
the calling seeker to become one
fine
license permit voucher document of
authority temporary pass travel coupon
and or certificate of authenticity good
old days we just asked for ID good old
days are gone
haven't seen one of these before orange
level you are some kind of badass just
someone with a job to do and the tools
to do it obviously go on through
another
okay hands behind your back
don't forget about your permit
authentication card would hate we go
and serious I saw him last night out
behind
I believe he was injured
idiots straightest off-limits Orbach
private function
our businesses are temporarily closed
rookie no pride
my god he was pretty sure
anomaly detected trace program initiated
access granted
raining
right
and anything
and of the place I shoot up to place
that our three
I looked everywhere
he's not here
I see
Feli the more angry we get
it's only
Jennsen thank God
I'm down in the dungeon man you remember
the title of my super secret book right
I remember it you read